الوصول الى اوريخيف هو دخول لمدينه اشباح
بشوارعها الفارغه ومتاجرها المدمره
تقع على بعد سبع كيلومترات من خط الجبهه
ويقصفها الجيش الروسي يوميا قبل الحرب كان
عدد سكانها 14 الف شخص بقي منهم ما يقارب
الالف
اختار استني سلاف البقاء يعيش في هذا
البيت مع والدته فالنتينا بالنسبه لهم فان
مغادره منزلهم وارضهم امر غير وارد
تسمح لي صحتي بالتحرك كثيرا منذ ان اجريت
عمليه جراحيه في الفخذ قبل خمس سنوات
هذه ارضنا اعتدوا على العمل فالحقل هنا
كيف يمكنني ترك كل هذا والرحيل
على ايقاع القصف تعيش فالنتينا في قلق
مستمر
ان كنت خائفه ام لا لا استطيع النوم منذ
عده ايام
هذا الصباح كانت لدي ترتعج واصابني دوار
من التعب لكننا ننجو كل مره
في حيهم لم يبقى سوى عدد قليل من المنازل
قائما لم يدمر جميع جيرانهم الى الهرب
وبقي يعيش في شارعهم خمسه اشخاص فقط
استيقظنا عند الثانيه صباحا لان النوافذ
والابواب فتحت بفعل انفجار قوي
فالجيراننا الى الشارع كل شيء احترق ولم
يبقى اي شيء
من تبقى من السكان في هذه المدينه يعرف
انها في خطر حقيقي ولكن تشبثهم بارضهم
وبيوتهم اكبر من خوفهم من هجوم روسي قد
يتزامن مع الذكرى السنويه الاولى